hello happy Monday
sorry we're late I'll take I'll take the
blame for that blimp a hashtag point a
you throw it into the chat if anyone
knows what that is basically it's when
something goes wrong everyone blames me
it's kind of like a recurring thing you
guys can use that going forward if you
want to but I'm Eric that's John Luke so
it's very green in the background for a
reason it's been ten years since Halo
3's come out and to celebrate that we're
gonna play the game we're currently
getting Xbox 360 info as you can see on
the screen so everybody backwards
compatible though we're doing the Xbox
one version which is 1999 I believe is
what we paid for there if you know if
you needed to buy it actually take you
go off to fullscreen for a second like
fullscreen camera or green camera okay
all right he wants to he wants to make
sure notifications because last time
move spammed my fans you up spammed me
up hard all right now do I go back or do
you all right wait I'm gonna hold but I
hope you guys are all doing well today
and are ready for some halo three we're
gonna play some story obviously and
we're gonna see if anyone's playing with
multiplayer if they are we'll get into
some multiplayer games if not hey
there's always story so all right you're
good we're good
all right I don't know if this is the
best oh hey some halo the best spot for
the pit but I will sort it out once we
get going
all right here we go all right
hey matchmaking update like three for
three
this apparently comes with like all the
DLC okay cool which is cool
why not Master Chief collection as gams
at a buck are off yeah we're playing the
og urgent also it's a smaller and
smaller files it download yeah that's
the actual reason but we're gonna say
it's because let's keep my wow I totally
keeps my progress all your stuff rad
nice we can do the beginning or we can
pick like do you do you Gianluca man
what's the best level do you do you
probably the art the artists later I'll
do a rival row wick oh yeah you playing
heroic oh yeah all right
the theme gets me every time since I
work man
yeah god damn I'm twenty five ten years
ten years ago I was fifteen Jesus I'm
all it's a goof Google is it goggled old
Chicago Jesus yeah I am a legendary
edition in my son's house shoes side
work man says back when Wendy was
actually good I got a hate I didn't I
watched as you became the soldier we
needed you to be like the others you are
strong and Swift and brave a natural
leader but you thought something they
didn't something no one saw me
[Music]
can you guess
look
[Music]
disclaimer I played halo and halo 5 I
didn't play in between because I'm not
owned at 360 or any of that and you know
from one of the best things is the worst
one like yeah that's right that's right
you it's tough I only played halo
because my friend had a 360 so it was
like okay or no it's not even a 360 an
Xbox
yeah yeah I always just had Playstations
myself personally can have both you know
you got a like I had a Genesis instead
of snez I couldn't have both well these
are the human faces in Halo 3 are
[Music]
Mario cat wants you to collect all 13
skulls yeah man let's do it woman I can
do that Jeff surrett says you better
find Louis skulls I want to see that
birthday headshot I think I have a Mario
I probably have a Morlock don't hug me
gamespot I don't even know who that is
that's probably I don't know who that's
it could be calling me out I'm the one
in charge of chat that's weird ah man
it's not been cuz Ben just messaged that
he thinks three is the best in the
series that's philanthropy in the
YouTube hey I'm gonna guess Rob Rob does
love him someone else said three was
liked by the best one these four
thoughts I would say 3 has is the best
overall Pacific preferences with my sir
I will adjust the audio I think it's us
being low relative to the game so I just
keep thinking of the game's not that
loud but it is and it's probably
overwhelming our voices but I will also
take a look at potentially boosting or
audio but thank you for that
Brandon Griffin this is the backwards
compatibility version of Halo 3 not the
Master Chief collection loading screen
boom that's going really fast
that's way faster than it used to go
sure yes it sure is not with SIBO could
be feel like I've had a lot of placebo
effects arbiter my boy it's a Cyberman
yeah man David hi good walk it off -
alright checking sensitivity check this
game control game controls 5 which is
apparently medium yeah it falls to 30
more like the game volume is low but you
two are fine okay I'll boost it up a
little bit a smidge and if it gets hit
with three controls kind of weird for
you tell me
I forgot feel like this is a good level
you gotta hit the bumper to reload
gunnery sergeant Hartman this game
taught me to hate aliens damn straight
talking about spacing I know I know are
there any other kind okay fine that's
fair
tell me if that's better free spirit
spirit now
I am shocked that they're not doing a
remaster this one hi yeah they came out
and said that they weren't right they
said they weren't 100% because it would
have come out today I was convinced they
were doing it cuz they did it for 1/2 an
hour self they're gotta do it for 3 and
that would be in like that would be the
big one right yeah especially with no
major halo this year and then it would
run in like 4k right thank you it's good
cool thank you
yeah I gotta get back to how this plays
getting like destiny or something I get
that I understand
this is the original backward-compatible
Brian this oh yeah dual wield action one
to take off the shield right even I know
that
see I might not be a halo veteran oh my
god do I know what what you need to use
at least in like competitive play I play
mostly multiplayer but the story was
always really good try and get into that
hole and coop coop was like the big
thing and like people were so salty in
five because there's no like local co-op
good screen and like I'm kind of curious
I know they haven't announced six but
six isn't gonna be a theme right Oh deaf
obviously so I'm just curious if they're
gonna have they are three for three
saying like yeah we're gonna what's the
last big game you've seen that actually
has like yeah like a split screen local
go it's been a while even 82,000 oh okay
screen
you can actually toggle it slip screen
or not
speaking of divinity if you guys are
interested someone's in that game it's a
there's a lot of cool stories in the
office haven't already but we're
interested we have some beginner tips
that are up now and then I think our
review should be soon like maybe
we're dawei about the Jesus s skull
nearby oh yeah
all right good call thank you thank you
for reminding me I like I'd like a yeah
please remind us memory of where all the
skulls are excitement collected at games
Bob please play Cortana it's the hardest
mission in all the Halo series oh it's
the worst mission in all the hail he
says he wants us to play it on legendary
get out of yo do people still play Halo
5 that was Chris don't miss I don't know
I think people still play the multi
multi player D player is actually pretty
good yeah that was the one thing that
was pretty good I remember I think like
you and Rob we're like okay at least the
the multiplayer is still like very solid
and light is a redeeming quality of that
game but I didn't know the backwards
it's by far the worst campaign in the
entire series and not just from a story
perspective but from like an actual like
layout like playing it's just
Ben aka philanthropy each each a saying
we should have turned on i wh b yd and
grunt birthday party we should have I
couldn't I could maybe do that for the
next level
okay Liz illa says God bless hallo
thanks GameSpot you got it skull count
one correct sickening same halo three
graphics were so good for their time and
Silla holds up pretty well today yeah
some things not as well like the faces
that was a big thing like reach fix like
I remember like engine slowing but it
was like hey we hired like a J's iam
zero zero six sixes which I said wanting
Ross guarantee Slovenian heroes
yeah I think that's like Jack Spiro
except with a B instead of an a it says
Halo Reach
all the way Jib on the other hand says
that I thought halo 3 looked quite
subpar for the time the animation
interfaces were below standard for the
time I think there are certain aspects
of it but yeah you know I think people
had a high expectation of the graphics
anything about like 1 & 2 and how
amazing that looks like hot okay the big
thing about halo I mean we play by far
the biggest just like events in gaming
all sorts of promotion the media
coverage was insane
people were talking about all the fun
promos that palos had Halo 3 has had
rather halo 3 has some really good like
commercials my TV yeah it's the one with
the yeah that was the one that Ben was
saying was the one that's the diorama
one really good I remember not only that
but Bulletstorm I remember gge
either like gee juice or something sorry
for butcher your name
male 3 digital groundbreaking at the
time especially for console halo 3 yeah
I don't know that's his opinion just the
cat food in a launcher or the brief shot
just saying crisis Bioshock and Cod for
it came out that year and it kind of
spoiled yeah robber talking about like
best years in gaming and and the two
that I always would go to Ono right they
changed it you can do it
98 he's the big one everyone so that's
ocarina half-life Metal Gear there's a
couple others as well like it was like a
really nice as you said half-life tell
about their time banjo kazooie starcraft
brood war Krypton tango thief baldur's
gate pokémon red and blue there's even
more oh this is a game particle how
fortuitous
I got to go down list Metal Gear I
should mention that's kind of yeah that
was a good year three Bioshock Modern
Warfare I don't work there were told
orange box of tickles it's too much yep
you set Bioshock Mario Galaxy Mario
Galaxy yes somehow the darkness made it
on here or these are just games I can't
Tiberium son I'm in half-life 2 Oh
burning through taking a lot that's
phasing so that for me was like the 2
ohm aspect one aspect yeah sorry I'm
just going through the list here taking
a look crackdown like yeah for sure
this is been a crazy year - I was
thinking about like we were we were
talking about just like Game of the Year
just how many games yeah you know it's
one of those things where these could
you sacrifice me it just slows now we're
trying to do through and scape as well
but it's just like man like daily try to
organize this just like he's almost
through whispers if you just play all
all these game
it's tough to write because it's like
not everyone's gonna enjoy the same
genre of game but having just like that
wide amount of like games coming out
just means that there's something for
someone right especially in a year like
that and it's always good though and I
feel like like it's really interesting
hearing you guys currently talking about
divinity almost in the same way that we
were talking about Zelda because all
these cool moments are happening all
these like oh my god did this happen to
you or like this this particular thing
happened to me or I didn't know this
thing worked this way kind of thing so I
think it's cool when there's a lot of a
lot of stuff a lot of good games out
that people are enjoying and sharing
there
we're gonna have and it's like how does
this feel for you
well I yelling been dank basically
saying everyone when I spend nothing my
board girlfriend choose like
quite a lot of enemies
although it's got multiplayer and I
offered like hey Adam told me we are
playing on heroic apparently that is a
level of gaming it has been 10 years did
you came to think about makes me feel
real watch out there's a sniper
music music it's great old man teh
correct unknown gamer holy [ __ ] 10 years
oh the memories this is nostalgic as
well oh it's nice death number one
remember remember the death guy blew 93
this is the 360 version we're playing
backwards compatibility currently
playing on an Xbox one X right so it's
maybe getting a little boost and
framerate yeah the original game ran out
like 30 and if we were to play the
massive collection it would be running
at tinnies don't rip number two John
which one glad you're alright rip
counter - that's alright though I'm just
giving you a hard time
sweet you guys playing destiny the
precursor I suppose the jackal forest
you guys should come up we could later
good I'm gonna let John Luke kind of
handle the range myself yeah basically I
don't want it falls in this okay oh boy
all right I got start laughing at his
because if it was me wanted me it'd be I
feel justice so kill that guy there we
go now we can deal with this guy
nailed it Wow I like how he's shot as he
was dying that was a badass move right
there
oh we're for now but yeah hey you guys
opportunity anchor
I'll be for those who don't know we're
playing Halo 3 the remastered not the
remaster halo 3 the backward
compatibility first on the Xbox go shots
for me arbiter 6 gig download 1999
what's out notes go guys asleep
pitching yeah no I don't know how to
close combat fight oh boy Korean guy I
think or I don't even know you got some
weird emoji name thanks for your kind
words will do better feels like for sure
goggled he won't say Google Goggles
Jesus worst guys on the game are jackals
with the snipers hand yeah I see that
evidence in what I just saw in the last
chance
TV a TV fit yeah to be fair Thank You
mr. beatbox says jackal tempers have
been a pain since Taylor to the AI our
sniper pros emoji name person they have
aimbot & wallhack
and they have everything that you can
think of they definitely any mod well at
first I could like all your names are
really small on my water so at first it
kind of looked like kind of like on V or
like not roll monkey kanji or like that
kind of stuff because we do have some
international folks that stop by
sometime so I thought it was like a
perhaps a korean handle but it's
starting to not look that way based off
of your reaction so all i can really
call you is like square two squares with
two - under
[Music]
all right level of gaming says of course
that a I have a BOTS their BOTS that's
true that was actually 100 percent true
oh yeah there you go
you gave me something I can't read that
though I thank you though
I don't know if I was right or wrong
based off of you putting that into cat
but
it sounds bad yeah I miss grunt save
yourself
was it Jason Jason always power weapon
Hey yeah so there he is do you guys
think can we still play PvP I'm
downloading the game right now I don't
know I was gonna ask you because I
thought you had finished the download
before us cuz I saw you in chat saying
that you're gonna try to do something
with Yuki Yuki we have not which is
currently playing store if I do another
store mission at least the arc and then
maybe we'll see if the multiplayer works
if it does maybe we'll hop in a mattress
to see if there's people matchmaking
if not we'll just play another story
mission call it a nice happy ten years
in Halo 3 happy birthday a decades-old
crazy the needler put that [ __ ] down now
it says no noble puffed heart seven
one English garbage dude head said I
don't have armor anymore please stop it
good night
that guy's going to town with his sword
I like it
wrong zero says I want to see a
variation of the needler returning the
Destiny to as an easter egg from this
game the closest thing to the needler in
destiny one was Telesto they basically
did the same thing it shot out like pink
needles
esque and then exploded
I missed the needler rifle from Halo
Reach
cyborg man saying this was one of those
games that lived up to the hype yeah I
would say so
Smith BMX bringing up those good old
family stories basically saying he grew
up playing Halo 3 at his cousins and
it's his favorite in the series I
remember those days for me it was the
snez and I got to play like Mario karts
Super Mario World and like Street
Fighter 2 turbo
because I didn't have a snez and I'd
always had to play on my team and he was
another one that I got to play
sonic man sanic
hello
the melee for the kneeler and halo 1
being like really powerful but I have
100 get sniped have a prolonged
animation them hackers durva 7 saying
hope you guys are having a great day
we're having a pretty good day nothing
like playing some halo 3 on a stream
celebrate 10 years of Halo 3 glad you
guys are tuning in not everyone's here
China DUP reminiscing nostalgia you know
we're live every day at 11 if you guys
didn't know that already and if you
haven't already you should hit that hot
sub button or follow button I'll see you
guys know when we'll go live tomorrow me
John Luke or Rob including three of us
two out of the three will probably be
doing some hot destiny 2 weekly reset
for Destiny's children episode 3 so come
back in to tune in for a more advanced
version of Halo tomorrow but the same
folks that made this game
good sniping I like that page oh oh it's
at my arbiter oh nothing nothing
well you know what you didn't help me
out so I'm not gonna help you out all
right
no no I won't be 11 it'll be well it
should be 11 because they did
maintenance today lieutenant long says
Cortana oh I didn't eat the lemon ish
was him making fun yeah I know today
lieutenant long saying in YouTube chat
Cortana on legendary costed me two
controllers that's why we're not going
to do that level definitely not on that
difficulty I was like
is there a scholar there might be like I
don't trust you by chest like cyborg man
oh god the hammer guy who will win sword
or hammer
oh you through oh my gosh
come on John Luke that was a scummy move
probably would've did it in real life so
if I had this boy get into the bar Baird
Bard
oh there is a skull since Google Jesus
go somewhere gravity hammers ROP oh do
you know where it said scholars this is
not good skull on the on a Ledge you
have to climb
[Applause]
okay fine I don't behind it up the
building all the way at the end is what
is being advised but you know we don't
have to get it so that guy's a phalanx
got it oh we go into town
Oh your temper too bad get ready
I was like about to say there's no way
that guy's not dead
destiny needs those guys his armor
protected I was gonna happen no we're
not switching controller on death knight
flash as mentioned before I have played
halo and halo by nothing in between
come at me that's all right shame me if
you want I don't care but yeah that's
wrong no they don't play well when life
gives you lemons you make lemonade
Oh Harvard or get him win the sword
fight you can do it all right
the old two on one damn Johnson their
plasma grenades
I agree the lunatic 19 it's pretty
annoying been saying oh man remember the
dude we sniped the traffic cone and the
cone flew back into him and killed him
yes Bundy gave him recon armor for it
yes
remember the katana chest that's like
the flaming head thing
there's a thing where they were like oh
if you beat like a bunch employee and
like show it like I'll send you a steak
dinner
it's fine good we'll fight just skip
that to go
I mean I have them also turn them on
yeah hey flash 96.7 one guy who shot a
code I want to see it hey that's like
very Just Cause ish right there hello
video I believe it was in multiplayer
where he like mr. beatbox saying I
remember blowing up a brute chopper on
san chef only gets splatted by one of
the flaming wheel route chopper on sand
trap only to then get splattered by
wearing the flames yep friendly gunship
coming in hot coming in hot
stay alive
now he has technically all the skulls
group that's fine
it's his fine but thank you
so I do not have a every achievement
eighty-four Jeff Beck says I still say
the marketing for this game was better
than the a cross-border
storage storage
best campaign
okay it's my favorite
hello choose campaign is pretty good but
and then halo ones is good but very
repetitive like the the design gets
incredible
especially areas like
a prime example of that the whole game
kind of does that so things are kind of
harder to go back to we are totally
plugged in yeah
like outside the 360
I have F confirm contacts is built we're
gonna how are we going
skulls and we'll do we're gonna do the
art at a campaign options let's turn on
skulls let's turn on birthday party I
want to be your daddy and all these are
just really awful heroic do normal for
this one because this one's you could do
it
what I just I might do no all because it
was good this one's a a vehicle level
and I kind of want to just like have a
little freedom to run a risk playing
heroic have to be a little more cautious
about it which is fine but I don't know
tattoo saying the title stream of the
stream just makes me realize how old I'm
getting yeah same here it's a lot of
people a lot of people here realizing oh
crap it's ten oh crap
what's my yeah okay
freaks calling you out yeah that's fair
keep saying Eureka I mean you just
literally just hit okay
it's not batteries I don't think
starter Lord trip pastor it's like the
the elites of all cruises fire at will
burn them mongrel hides like the armored
stuff still looks pretty good you know
the cake sparks the attack how did that
ma'am we're on him
kick the door boggle Jesus no plans
currently for more halo just kind of
play them anniversaries like ya mean a
lower Robert yeah you and halo hello
just for fun in the office
you see that there
I'm an idiot all by it
[Music]
like Madonna that music tho Oh
don't worry Jacob you're not the only
one
you don't actually realize how how long
it's been till you actually see it and
you're like oh you get proposing happy
birthday happy birthday right seems very
palpable
well if it's almost Tayla ones that we
can't know wasn't about however 15 2001
I am wrong that would be 16 so I guess
we'll have to do something
yeah
[Music]
go in and mop him up expert mom thinks
that the other is the second controller
once we unplugged it we're good Alex
Bach says I can't be the only one who
purposely blew up my character just to
watch the ragdoll physics do that I
really write up those things are fun
wow this is it this is a stretch said
once everyone still looks better than
Mass Effect Andromeda now it's a funny
joke but I just had to give it out there
bring the hand
don't pinch it I bought it and hated it
he bought it and beat it and was not I
mean he made it through I did it but I
don't think he was very happy about no I
don't know why I did it by a hundred
percent of that game and I don't know
Wow a hundred percent well technically I
knew something but like I did everything
okay not hundred was like extra - guys
stop it's already dead
yeah that's that's awesome one half like
all right I have another good
god
there's a lot of love for Halo 3 it's
pretty cool oh yeah
needs to be harder but it'd be cool like
destiny
the online named Asteria backwards
compatible version
honey comb and switch that telling us
that they hate their robots in each halo
for more than the flood go here they've
got these terminals
it's a servitor tell the story of the
forerunners and stuff it's like really
cryptic and references stuff in like
marathon it like links the two universes
together for old-school Bungie fans that
stuff so I relate everything to destiny
so that could have been like we're more
for me all the ideas no DSO DST has
[Music]
pictured ravioli went down we spotted
the Gouda first started you to where
they're gonna go right yeah see ya it's
pretty cool to get for crossing your
arms
I feel like it's smooth all right some
hot vehicle action all right
before desperate anymore with that
little quality
which really wants you want to take this
thing
guys your nanny
Nick Doyle saying easily shake up I
easily pick up a used halo 3 for less
than five year old oh yeah
so the party
in game
oh oh you got two guys dead your third
guy it's just you we're your buddies
don't worry Master Chief always have to
take care of it
want something done you do it yourself
oh gosh
right solo
all right there we go we didn't take 19
it's not a fan of the chopper chopper
good
Falco Jesus saying like yeah with what
you left I cried
I know
but you said personally for your halo 3
right campaign wise you might say
all right so far so good
probably
the hell was that
to me like go to his solar ball spirit
bomb it's coming
that's what I get me episodes later
you what's our rib counter five
okay we got we all feel a little
as we tell you this is now a 10 years
old halo 3 so solid
yeah not over
not react
here we go
DJ saved me and you to test after you
tested multiplayer yet
[Music]
does this still do that halo thing where
if you're bouncing when you get hit
Christene Ohana's I have watched Oh
I don't know nothing has beat pickle
Rick from personally you guys should
turn them right the one with the one
with the council where it's put the
count of indicators it's basically like
in anthology where it's just going
through like all the Morty's and that
was this season let me get you the right
name oh my god I got it I got it
and I know we could go to our sister
site KCI universe who covers Rick and
Morty good segue and it was was it from
Rick lantus yes it was the name was that
alluding probably my favorite line
blowers that was a good like replacement
for the like it's fair I thought that
one was fine yeah bit too much Mike now
okay I can't win I turned down the
gameplay you yeah oh you're not as bad
yeah project I have you have max right
now but I can't turn it I just need to
project more yeah
okay do I not get a vehicle
they gave me a vehicle here they told
you your EFT secret take the chopper get
into the chopper
chimichangas Deadpool you're watching
some hot halo three
backwards-compatibility on the Xbox one
s for us okay there is a skull up here
alright remember this one I'll check for
that okay well it's up to you if you
want to try it or not if you don't we
can just proceed it's fine saber can
saying I love how there's no fall damage
in this game
are you gonna try
it was just like oh you don't have
legendary he said the skulls are only on
legendary is that true that was cipher
can I was playing on her oh can I have
the skull earlier there's something with
difficulty so maybe it's like a rogue oh
that's fine
Alex I know it's there gotcha all right
Alex box asking best halo 3 moment for
you I don't have ones like probably the
one coming up with the scarab is my
favorite
mady's I just I was like it's so much
fun alright the old warthog cyber Cain
says my bed I was wrong
alright at least you admitted to it so
there you go okay
[Music]
already failed already a failure hi guys
good luck that dish my bad guys I kind
of flipped over the Warthog but I guess
I'll go deal with this guy by myself
oh that just reminds me of Starship
Troopers freako just going up to that
big flaming beetle and punching a hole
or shooting a hole in dough and dumping
grenade in them boy and no boy boy and
nor I'll make sure to pop this in this
week oh I think they maybe took it yeah
over there oh you're good
it survived it's funny I did honeycomb
this part is the hardest in the mission
maybe the party already just did alright
cuz they're catching up maybe was the
part that you just did yeah I remember
this part being kind of tough when
you're playing online
you know the a a race which yeah there
is a really able to get in those or
something
those wrecks of kneeling a million Oh
[Music]
and plenty of Gardens back there man I
think the sprint is real tough
close one
don't mind if we do my health back
Robert handle REE says I should be
getting lunch but I want to see the UN
us and see ship roll up here that's work
currently this for this mission we only
went to normal I gotta be careful in
this part because the debris can kill
you
like I'm cheating by that yeah that's
cool
get a good view
[Music]
that's Hank honeycomb saying he actually
thinks halo is best without the spring
philanthropy aka Ben Gingka the most
badass shipping all of halo shows up in
3d I've always loved the names of or
dental dawn pillar of autumn I wanted to
I don't know but uh been literal shows
up in this one took three lines to write
tank beats everything
tank beats oh yeah he'll hear
happy birthday
physics thank doesn't eat everything
ting doesn't eat having debris on the
ground okay we're good
[Music]
[Music]
rocking gamer this game was and still
amazing goober Eicher driving skills at
four out of ten do you have the side
machine gun for the Scorpion in Halo 3 I
don't know Rob's asking about the their
side machine gun the scorpion there is a
there is a side machine gun but the
second person asking yeah you don't get
a controller yourself
someone has to get in it alright
I don't think you parallel part things
even if you did have to parallel park a
tank I think it'd be really easy because
you just roll up on all the cars that
are like judging your way just like yep
did it nailed it to another ten parallel
park
I could try get out of here
tank beats everything
Roberts asking me isn't in a secondary
weapon not an unfree I can't shoot with
it you have to be ID'd there I'm trying
to yeah I don't see what he's saying no
no that wasn't halo 1 & 2 I believe it
was three they changed it with you I
don't know what the effort room where
they did with 4 & 5
technically calm we are currently
playing on xbox 1 s backwards compatible
version Rob you went beyond tomorrow for
hit destiny depends on how busy don't
Lucas I'll definitely be on those
because it's like you get to do the
nightfall and so yeah yeah it works out
yeah this is gonna be a crazy week
scream excited probably yeah if you guys
didn't know John Luke does a bunch of
our history of he's done like three or
four now and he's doing another one soon
we get to say what it's about yeah we're
doing the Lord of the Rings I promised
Mario fortune for joining it just for
the timing of sake it made more sense
the shadow
yeah shadow this week Mario still
happening yeah because that one's coming
out and death day which is like a hard
day death day for you guys but on the
27th there's assassin screed origins
there's a Wolfenstein 2 and there's also
Super Mario crazy day
so shadow of war door will be it's early
October right I forget the exact date I
want to say like God 15 I think
yeah the 10th initial release date says
the 10th it's in a couple weeks
watch the nice thanks Matt more so yeah
if you are interested in any of those
other ones he's done he's on Sonic
satins Creed 2d Metroid games and
one there right uncharted uncharted
there you go
that's for about halfway through sorry
to hear that BG Floyd it's unfortunate
alright I think have to what's up dragon
flaming HD how are you doing today
thanks pelipper thanks for tuning in and
nice words art it gig edge I'm assuming
you're talking about halo three all
right here it is try to get you the date
fair part of the game so September 25th
2007 which is why happy birthday Oh dip
I got trouble John Luke alright form of
a big a scarab
yeah you run you scared them away I'm
gonna take nineteen can't wait for the
new Wolfenstein my body is ready yeah
there's a couple people in the office
that are like you know for that I can't
wait I'm actually a little bit curious
about Assassin's Creed origin just
because they're trying to do like a more
like Dark Souls II type combat but I
heard it's kind of not that in as
in-depth as I thought it might be that
was from preview so good yeah there's
some interesting stuff with that also
you know me I like the looped oh yeah
all about the loot and Mario is gonna be
crazy
Mario so much just gives the way we kind
of give you up games in the office
Wolfenstein yeah on the video but at
least with that one you'll be able to
get through it in like where's Mario
such a like yeah yeah so well I'm very
excited playing that I'll probably
switch to yeah
get in there all right how do I want to
take out this I don't know what's your
best tried in treatment and that's like
driving okay all right that's mine uses
pieces Hale three what's ash it still is
Tafel or tall FL guy I think is what it
is
any halo 6 news 2019 maybe no we haven't
heard anything other than it like will
happen and that I guess someone else in
chat had said that they will have
split-screen co-op
that's kind of like the news we have I
wouldn't be shocked if we get an
announcement like next year maybe like
III or something because even this year
they're kind of light on Xbox exclusives
I really thought they would have
something keys for Xbox one X but they
didn't Halo wise so maybe we're looking
at some type of announcement or teaser
next year perhaps and maybe they'll do
that that kind of needs theme where I
feel like more companies are doing the
here's a trailer for the game Oh guess
what it's actually coming out this fall
or something you know what I mean I set
up like a longer building all right what
do you gonna do try to drive up on it
all right Gentiles going for the the big
plays for the big plays it's better with
a ghost it's night board man wants evil
within - real bad that's coming out
Friday 13th right nailed it good won't
you try again oh yeah can you or
make this work there's like um filled up
but not so much me that ghost is coming
feast
[Music]
still good don't stop on us please
oh oh yo you know some vehicle the
chopper
Oh or you could get lazy way well it
should just be here we go here we go
okay go up there I might be a chopper
ooh yes
oh yeah the portal portal gravel is
thanks cyber can
you
come IQ Drew's still hoping this cuz
ported to PC in my lifetime that would
be nice there was a dream for
nailed it ten out of ten landing stuck
it basically just want the halo Olympics
Wallace ice yep thank you for the tip
basically just Oh God
Oh like a nice little Michael Bay
scenario
that's pretty much the peak of this
level yeah I know that's fine okay so
what we can do here is why don't you try
seem multiplayer works we can try one
game if it works and then we'll call it
shame if it doesn't work we'll just
still college team because I thought
that was pretty pretty solid but you
said happy birthday to hail a tree with
a Sukkot scarab I mean the surface is
still long people are playing you gotta
just go with the one that has the most
what do you think would be team Slayer
MLG so we can find out 404 gamers online
let's just do some all right some Slayer
oh you know what we're kind of locking
your name so this worked out the social
Slayer is populated that makes sense
uh-oh our net types not open that seems
about right I could switch it to the
other port in which case a population of
104 social Slayer it populated thanks
for your front probably think I'm on
rank Slayer right now so we'll see if
I'm not getting anything the sec jump of
the year yeah if it doesn't work I can
also try putting you into the other port
that I think is more of an open net site
multiplayer on three four pcs where is a
thing so you might be thinking been of a
halo custom edition which was halo one
that free version of a loved one on PC
people have been like modding that thing
for years and putting in like maps and
guns from Halo like although later Halo
games so maybe you're thinking of that
I only try let's try the social one
social Slayer social playlist yes social
Slayer that doesn't work I'm gonna
quickly try swap in the Ethernet ports
we have one that's more friendly than
the other all right we got a higher
population plus 80 if that doesn't work
what I call a stream because it's pretty
pretty good but we'll see online yes all
right they're also made a version of
Halo called halo online which was a
China only yeah oh three players for
players I remember that as well yes it's
probably actually sweet looks like we're
gonna get it one match to kind of wrap
it wrap this happy birthday stream up
don't know let's find out is it gold I
don't know just making stuff like I'll
plug gold yeah I don't know what
Guardian guardian spine soon be ours
it's their replacement for lockout not
as good as actual lockout then they just
put in lockout in Halo 3 DLC whatever
I'm happy to his feet hide nothing we
can't be do it oh yeah there you go it
just because I mean I'm okay with
Guardian but come on everyone else veto
everyone wants to play Guardian also
this team BR which is kind of whatever
it's fine alright I'm gonna get my
you're so enthusiastic also we team read
my scores here we go that I caught did I
just get over shield is that what that
was oh yeah you wouldn't need a little
needle it up
all right we up we took the lead oh man
this is really this is some vintage
stuff right here though I like it
oh yeah you killed him right no no you
and this isn't like the friendlier FPS
games nowadays where the best have some
points you did it you did you did a
thing oh come in hat needs lord shaxx be
oh dude lord shaxx in Japanese [ __ ] you
know I always forget how good grenades
are in this game and I don't use them
enough oh he's got a hammer we killed
him nice
well fade away fade away grenade look do
you wanna take his camera it's alright
it's about swaggin yeah it's best swag
points about the hot flank moose
torturer one seven five do you think D 2
will have 66 million no I don't think so
when we search her it would be nice
honestly yeah I kind of miss 66 and
destiny but they've gone with the four
before routes ok I think it's fine
as I had mentioned she's some people
before it just kind of exposes some of
the some of your your weaker teammates
whereas with 66 you could kind of mask
that a little bit more but I think it's
fine
okay duel with Stu wielding the plasmas
combination it's okay yeah let's do all
right so far close match
16:14 that guy's doing work though APB I
mean your best strategy in these games
usually just stick with the battle rifle
yeah doc that is the best guy I think I
stole your kill sweet grenade action oh
yeah have a good name don't stop the
ball all right
overshield that's good dialo says VR is
the best gun alright we're pulling away
red team's pulling away up six red
team's doing good I'm doing
yeah I'm loose torture I agree I mean
it's also weird too because I feel like
the maps are like way bigger and D - and
with only four people it's kind of weird
but he does the challenge okay
did the old cover his own tracks with
the grenades now he's running John Luke
is on the case though yeah oh hey what
happened I guess traded that's fine
we'll take it
cuz that guy hadn't vis right yeah a PV
you guys doing work oh they may or may
not bring back rifts or whatever you're
fine I mean I think it's been a good
like one two one oh yeah oh no you
didn't get damnit mcil oh this is yeah
he doesn't see you he's a biessing Oh
word
and prophet of regret thinks that
destiny too is very average that's your
opinion
honey it's a solid agrees I'm not saying
it's like yeah yeah this guy doesn't
know what's up this guy's a day one halo
3 player like I would be Reese's Pieces
his favorite gun is and always will be
envious all right we got the shotgun
[Music]
yeah you do pretty good middle of the
pack here the sorrowful has gone through
many iterations
I think Halo four and five has been at
its best
there we go
oh nice read BAM and this guy thinks he
can come out with the hammer here oh
it's all about that a last hit yeah I
saw there are some of the hit markers on
those like you said hey you told me
yourself it was unreliable you should
hold smashed him alright back to your
your favorite the need left it'll need
learn some people say you got robbed
there I feel the same way I got the one
guy though I did you okay I think so
yeah I couldn't tell we're there yet
yeah yeah get need alert Oh
got him
did you yeah nice nice they don't call
it all the reliable for nothing John
Luke
alright three three more to win it be a
beauty to send out on a win here to go
out on a win with John Luke getting that
final kill a sweet double right here
there's one yeah I think one more kill
oh yes this is the run no get him
anyways yeah right that's what I'm
talking about
play the game play the game right there
that's pretty cool I think it's not
gonna get better than that I am a
recruit now oh they definitely reset my
rank though oh that's that's all right
but that's definitely the way to go out
I feel like a great day halo three out
well backwards-compatible now if you
want to ten ten years old just crazy and
weird yeah
but yeah good job John Luke thank you
yeah I'm glad skills exactly never went
away it kind of warmed up as you played
the single-player a little bit sometimes
you just got to get a little bit of that
familiarity that muscle memory again but
yeah cool tomorrow as mentioned before
destiny to Destiny's children our third
stream with that that's gonna be
tomorrow at 11:00 it'll either be what
this combo or like me and Rob or some
type of combination between the three
but it'll probably mean Rob it sounds
like unless he he finds some time but
we'll find out we'll see anyways you
guys for tuning into that and until next
time have yourselves a wonderful Monday
and see you guys later thanks
you